this one was a challenge hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by better
help and we'll be taking a look at
downshiftology but first let me tell you
about my sponsor betterhelp so as you
guys know i have been very open about my
struggles with anxiety for
pretty much my whole life and as we're
gonna discuss today
stress and anxiety play a really
important role in physical health as
well as mental health so i've been
really focusing on my mental health and
working with a registered therapist is
key to supporting my goals so i recently
discovered betterhelp which is the
world's largest online therapist network
with over 20 000 licensed professional
therapists it's not a crisis line or a
self-help line it's professional therapy
done securely anywhere anytime online
the way it works is that you just log
into your account any time of day and
you can send a message to your therapist
and you get a timely response without
needing to wait weeks between
appointments i know how important this
is because obviously we can't plan out
when we're gonna have like a panic
attack or we're gonna have an anxious
episode to have it coincide the week of
our scheduled appointment it's also a
lot more affordable than traditional
in-person therapy and there's also
financial aid available for those in
need so if you're struggling with your
mental health check out betterhelp.com
abby's kitchen to get 10 off of your
first month of therapy that's better
h-e-l-p and you can join over 1 million
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional and you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my general disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating and if you are
not already subscribed hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
follow me over on tick tock and
instagram at abby's kitchen today's
video is going to be a journey we're
about to go on together i have been
requested so many times to tackle
downshiftology which is a popular meal
prep channel brought to us by food
blogger lisa bryan and the reason i have
admittedly waited up until now is that
lisa's case is probably one of the most
unique and more complicated cases that
i've seen here on youtube so after being
diagnosed with four autoimmune diseases
lisa decided to change up her eating
habits and lifestyle in an effort to
improve her symptoms while also
inspiring her audience with her
autoimmune friendly recipes and meal
prep videos so cases like these are
quite complex for us dietitians because
we have to very carefully investigate
how each of the disease recommendations
overlap or contradict each other while
also paying attention to the
individual's unique experience but when
people watching at home follow a cookie
cutter recommendation that they see from
like a wellness content creator i feel
that they risk very very dangerous
consequences for their own unique case
so after a lot of research and a large
team effort you and i are about to go
through this case together honestly even
i'm a little shook let's get to it my
test results came back and i was off the
charts for celiac disease from there the
autoimmune connection was discovered and
the diagnosis seemed to roll right in
one after the other with hashimoto's
psoriasis and endometriosis yeah like
the girls got
a lot going on so in order to understand
lisa's case
let's break down first of all what an
autoimmune disease actually is simply
put an autoimmune disease is a condition
where the immune system attacks part of
the body that it mistakes as foreign
even though they are otherwise perfectly
healthy cells this results in
inflammatory response which increases
inflammation in the body along with
other symptoms that are generally
related to the part of the body that is
being attacked
so in lisa's case with hashimoto's
disease the immune system is attacking
the thyroid psoriasis attacks skin cells
celiac attacks part of the gi tract and
endometriosis affects cells of the
uterus now though it's technically not
classified as an autoimmune disorder
endometriosis will usually fall into
this category because it is inflammatory
in nature now the exact causes of most
autoimmune disorders are difficult to
pin down though genetics diet and stress
are considered likely contributors now
what we do know is that it is very
common for autoimmune disorders to
overlap and honestly that makes for some
waters for diagnosis proper treatment
and diet recommendations i dropped about
200 on gluten-free packaged food to fill
up my fridge in pantry but instead of
feeling better i actually felt worse and
i triggered candida and sibo i'm sure
from all of the sugars and starches that
i was eating in those packaged foods
that my body just wasn't used to it
completely threw off my gut microbiome
okay so if you haven't been following
along with my sibo saga which you can
watch right here sibo aka small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth is a
condition where there's an excessive
amount of bacteria in the small
intestine resulting in bloating gas and
other digestive symptoms along with some
symptoms like weakness and fatigue
candida on the other hand is a fungal
infection that gets triggered when the
healthy bacteria in our body kind of
gets disrupted or our immune system is
compromised which results in things like
fatigue utis oral thrush and also
digestive distress so yeah lots of not
so hot symptoms going on at once for
this young woman this must be very very
hard now as for the gluten-free products
triggering these conditions i would say
that's probably not what's going on i
mean it is possible that some
gluten-free products have more
triggering ingredients like starchy corn
or tapioca simple sugars or gums which
may exacerbate symptoms or kind of like
feed the bacteria or yeast but i did a
brainstorm session with my colleagues on
this and what we think is a more likely
explanation is that lisa probably
already had sibo and candida to begin
with but her celiac symptoms kind of
masked their existence so removing the
gluten resolved some of those symptoms
to allow others to become more obvious
is it that obvious i'm sorry and i know
it can feel like you take one step
forward just to take two steps back so
where did the sibo likely come from well
fifty percent of folks with celiac also
have sibo likely because celiac and
hashimoto's often slow down gut motility
so essentially food is moving slower
through the digestive tract and the
longer food particles aka bacteria fuel
are like hanging around in the gut the
greater risk for bacterial overgrowth as
for the candida because celiac damages
the intestinal lining it can impair the
immune system which makes it more likely
for bacteria to kind of get out of
control and trigger candida now candida
is also associated with hashimoto's
possibly because the immune system may
mistake the thyroid gland for an
existing candida infection and
essentially launch an attack
another theory is that candida may cause
leaky gut aka intestinal permeability
which is where the lining of the gut
gets damaged and undigested food
particles and toxins are able to leak
through and enter the bloodstream this
can then trigger an inflammatory
response and everything else kind of
just snowballs from there so with my
investigative dietitian hat on when i
piece these puzzle pieces together i can
see that least conditions likely feed
into one another in some sort of way and
while it can be a bit of a chicken and
egg situation we do know that solving
this puzzle likely comes down to the
integrity of the gut more specifically
intestinal permeability and an impaired
migratory motor complex let me break it
down so as i mentioned because the gut
is weakened by celiac or candida it can
cause intestinal permeability and the
leaking of contents into the bloodstream
to trigger a systemic inflammatory
response and i think a lot of western
medicine practitioners still dismiss
intestinal permeability or leaky gut
because it's not yet a real medical
diagnosis and honestly i'm often tempted
to do so as well because wellness
influencers love to just chalk
everything up to leaky gut but it is an
actual phenomenon with clinical markers
that is acknowledged in the research
it's just not likely the root problem
that so many health gurus claim it to be
for everything as for the other piece or
the migratory motor complex i mentioned
or mmc so we know that hashimoto's and
celiac both can slow down gut motility
which may impair the mmc so if you
recall for my sibo saga the mmc acts as
like this big broom to kind of sweep
bacteria and food particles along the
intestine so not having an adequate or
strong enough mmc allows bacteria to
basically hang out there and pool and
populate in the bowel which can trigger
things like sibo so bottom line we got
to heal that gut and i really evaluated
what i was putting into my body and how
i was living my life i swapped processed
foods for whole nutrient-dense foods i
focused on reducing stress improving
sleep and prioritizing self-care almost
all of these symptoms that i had had for
decades started to vanish in the
following weeks and months including the
allergies the fatigue the eczema the
constipation and the chronic colds okay
so this is very interesting so i liaised
with my dietitian colleague dasha
ignulic about this case and she said her
first goal in a situation like this
would be to lower the chronic
inflammation and get the gut in check to
help down regulate the autoimmune
response so one strategy for lowering
chronic inflammation is to evaluate what
dasha calls the speed pillars which
stands for sleep personal stress
environmental stress exercise and diet
so while most wellness influencers would
pull up a list from dr google of all the
foods to eliminate we need to first
determine the stressors that are likely
triggering the inflammation in the first
place as per the speed pillars it makes
tons of sense to me that improving sleep
and stress management helped to reduce
lisa's symptoms especially considering
that she was functioning in a perpetual
state of burnout all throughout her 30s
as
so many of us are as for dietary
recommendations for autoimmune disorders
it is unfortunately not as cut and dry
as prescriptive advice like get enough
sleep or reduce stress in general it is
highly highly individualized as there's
limited research and a ton of nuance
that we need to be sensitive to in fact
someone could have the exact same
conditions as lisa and require a
completely different protocol so with
celiac disease we need to completely get
rid of all the gluten so that means no
wheat rye barley malt or triticale with
hashimoto's disease some folks may do
well on a gluten-free diet where others
find that gluten-free greens trigger
them even more but the focus should be
on nutrients for thyroid function like
iodine zinc vitamin d magnesium selenium
and iron i have a whole video on this
that you can check out right here
psoriasis is another mixed bag with very
little quality research and no standard
diet protocol the evidence for
gluten-free is admittedly mixed and
inconclusive but we do want to focus on
getting enough omega-3 fats vitamin d
selenium and probiotics with some
research to support the use of a
mediterranean-style diet and
endometriosis is another bag of tricks
but the focus is on reducing trans fats
and red meat with some folks feeling
better going gluten-free and of course
also we want to focus on increasing
antioxidant rich fruits and vegetables
fiber and omega-3s to help reduce pain
and inflammation now if i'm overwhelmed
just trying to communicate this i can
only imagine how lisa is managing so
with that said what would be my approach
in a highly complicated scenario like
this well i would say this is a case
where an already supervised elimination
diet is warranted to really get symptoms
under control after which foods would be
gradually reintroduced to track symptoms
and also better identify the
inflammatory triggers so lisa said she
tried the whole 30 diet which appeared
to work for her however someone else
with endometriosis may not tolerate
whole30 as it is typically higher in
histamines which may increase estrogen
levels on the other hand some folks may
benefit from the autoimmune protocol
diet which similar to whole30 has very
limited research to support its use
however i did find one small study on 16
women with hashimoto's who followed the
aip diet for 10 weeks and inflammation
did decrease by 29
while disease-related symptoms decreased
by 68
other elimination protocols like dash's
core perform method combine a variety of
dietary approaches in one such as the
low fodmap low histamine whole30 paleo
and aip to better tease out trigger
foods for complicated cases like this so
again there is high high variability
here and one protocol may work for one
person and may not work for someone else
but the ultimate and eventual goal here
is to actually eliminate as few foods as
possible since diet variety is also very
important for the microbiome which we
also need to support this is why it is
just as important to focus on what we
can add by integrating more
anti-inflammatory foods luckily the
research is more aligned in this area
when it comes to treating autoimmune
disorders so for example we want to
prioritize things like omega-3 fats
vitamin d probiotics and antioxidant
rich foods these foods have also been
shown to benefit the gut barrier
function which would simultaneously
target the intestinal permeability piece
and lisa has certainly gotten the
anti-inflammatory memo because she
incorporates a wide variety of
anti-inflammatory foods in her diet
pretty much every day we also want to
once again pay attention to the speed
pillars and ensure that we're tending to
our self-care to really target the
stressors that may be perpetuating some
of the inflammatory response and it does
sound like these lifestyle factors are
top of mind for lisa as well because she
breaks it all down in her healthy habits
video right here so taking a two-pronged
approach that a lowers inflammation and
b
improves gut health is in my
professional opinion the best strategy
for chronic condition cocktails like
this and if you've taken away anything
from this video is that you should never
copy the nutrition protocol of somebody
that you watch online always speak to a
trained dietitian and healthcare need
about your case and yes that was a lot
so
on that note that is all that i have for
you guys today thank you again to
betterhelp for sponsoring if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below and
subscribe to this channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]